checks with his queen and if you can
avoid all that if you're keep all your
pieces nice and safe it's game over
so yeah sometimes players i've noticed
especially when they learn the game they
rush they play too quickly when they've
done the hard work they're too eager to
get that win but not wesley oh wait one
second and okay oh wait one second did i
just like did i suggest the blunder and
did dare sleep wow
yeah bank of the movie you wanted to
play and the move wesley played himself
it's a blunder because now the white
king actually
no matter where it goes there are
consequences when the white king steps
up it's going to get checked by the
black queen and there's no safe hiding
place because if you start marching up
the board later on the black knight
might come to fork you
oh my god now a diagonal check with the
black queen and the white king can't
step up because the black knight would
go to the h3 square and fork the white
king and queen so it's actually going to
be a draw oh no
he snatched a draw from the
wow the jaws of defeat yeah the draw
from the jaws of defeat
wow liam fighting spirit there saving
him in this game and the white king just
has to yo-yo back and forth between
these two squares the steps and uh
there's just no escape no safe squares
to run to
check check check it's going to be a
draw wesley he blew it and liam saves
the day wow wesley so running off he was
so close now to
simply going uh